la vie ou la mort sur ses pancartes le
personnel soignant d'un centre
hospitalier new yorkais crie sa détresse
lors d'une rare manifestation une
trentaine d'infirmiers dénonce le manque
de masques blues et autres équipements
de protection qui les met en danger et
leur passion oui nous n'avons pas le
matériel nécessaire car notre système de
santé doit faire du profit et tout le
système fonctionne sur le profit ces
hôpitaux ont été construits comme des
machines à fonctionnement réduit et ils
ont juste le minimum de matériel
nécessaire au lieu de ce qu'ils
devraient avoir
mais il ne s'agit pas seulement des
équipements de protection
il ya aussi le fait qu'ils n'ont pas de
respirateur ils n'ont pas les outils
pour faire face aux situations de tous
les jours sans parler d'une pandémie
comme celle ci dans un état de new york
en crise frappé de plein fouet par le
coronavirus lé gouverneur andrew cuomo
va bientôt rendre le port du masque
obligatoire dans les espaces publics
je vais publier un décret qui stipule
que dans les espaces publics toute
personne doit porter un masque ou se
couvrir la bouche et le nez et elles
doivent aussi le faire dans les
situations où l'on ne peut pas maintenir
de distanciation social dans cet état du
nord-est américain
le nombre officiel de morts est déjà
plus élevé que celui de certains pays
entier au cimetière de greenwood le plus
grand de new york
le nombre de crémations et enterrements
a plus que doublé ces dernières semaines
et la nécropole arrive aux limites de
ses capacités
on en est arrivé à un point où on a dû
arrêter d'accepter des crémations en ce
moment où on accepte 1,25 par jour ce
qui dans le passé étaient ce qu'on
voyait pendant un samedi
particulièrement chargé mais aujourd'hui
on en a vingt à vingt-cinq chaque jour
de la semaine sauf le dimanche où on est
généralement fermés et on en profite
pour rattraper notre retard face à ce
nombre de morts toujours plus importants
ces images ont frappé les esprits ces
derniers jours
des corps recouverts de draps ou de
bâches sont transportés par des employés
en combinaison de protection pour être
enterrée dans la plus vaste fosse
commune de l'état sur l'idh art iceland
surnommé depuis bien longtemps
l'île des morts